i do think that index investing
if everybody did it won't work but for
another
considerable period index investing is
going to work better than active stock
picking where you try and know a lot
not a place like berkshire hathaway or
even the daily journal we've done better
than average
and now there's a question
why has that happened
why has that happened
and the answer is pretty simple we tried
to do less
we never had the illusion we could just
hire a bunch of bright young people and
they would know more than
anybody about canned soup and aerospace
and
utilities and so on and so on and so on
we never had that dream we never thought
we could get really useful information
on all subjects like jen cramer pretends
it tends to have
and
and
we always realized that we worked very
hard we could find a few things
where we were right
and the few things
were enough
and that that was a reasonable
expectation that is a very different way
to approach the process
and if you would ask warren buffett
the same thing that this investment
counseling did
give me your best idea this year
and you just followed warren's best idea
you would find it worked beautifully but
he was trying to know the whole he would
give you one or two stocks
he had more limited ambitions
i had a grandfather who was very useful
to me
my mother's grandfather and he was a
pioneer and he came out to iowa with no
money but youth and health
and took it away from the indians
he fought in the black hole he was a
captain in the blackhawk wars and he
he stayed there and he bought cheap land
and he he
he was
aggressive and intelligent and so forth
and eventually he was the richest man in
the town on the bank
and uh and highly regarded a
huge family and a very happy life
and
and
he had the attitude having come out to
iowa when the land was not much more
than a dollar an acre and having stayed
there until that blacktop soil
created a modern rich civilization and
some of the best land in the world
his attitude was that in a favored life
like his when you were located in the
right place you just got a few
opportunities if you lived to be about
90.
and the trick and coming out well was
seizing a few opportunities
that were your fair share that came
along when they did
and he told
that story
over and over again to the grandchildren
around him all summer and my mother who
had no interest in money remembered the
story and told it to me
but i'm not my mother's
natural
imitator
and i knew grandpa was right
and so i always knew from the very first
i was a little boy
that the opportunities that were
important that were going to come to me
were few and that the trick was to
prepare myself for seizing the few that
came this is not the attitude they have
in a big investment counseling thing
if they study a million things they can
know a million things
and that
of course
the result is almost nobody can
outperform an index whereas
i sit here with my
daily journal stock
my berkshire hathaway stock
my holdings at lilu's
asian fund
my costco stock
and of course i'm outperforming
everybody
i'm 95 years old
and i probably never have a transaction
and the answer is i'm right and they're
wrong
and that's why it's worked for me and
not for them
and
now the question is do you want to be
more like me or more like them
me
the idea of diversification
makes sense to a point
if you don't know what you're doing and
you want the standard result
and not be embarrassed well of course
you can widely diversify
nobody's entitled a lot of money for
recognizing that because it's a truism
it's like knowing that two and two
equals four
and
but the investment professionals think
they're helping you by arranging a dirt
diversification an idiot could diversify
a portfolio
and
or a computer for that matter
and and
but the whole trick of the game
is to have have a few times when you
know that something is better than
average
and
invest only where you have
that extra knowledge
and then if you get just a few
opportunities that's enough
and what the hell do you care you own
three securities and jp morgan chase
owns a hundred
you know it's
what's wrong with owning a few
securities
warren always says if you lived in a
growing town and
you owned stock and three of the best
enterprises in the town isn't that
diversified enough
the answer is of course it is they're
all wonderful places
and that fortunes formula which got so
famous
which
was a formula to tell people
how much to bet on each transaction
if you had an edge
and of course the bigger your edge the
more close the transaction was to a
certain winner
the more you should bet and of course
there's mathematics behind it
but of course it's true
it's perfectly possible to buy
by only one thing because the
opportunity is so great and such a saint
or only two or three so the whole idea
of diversification when you're looking
for excellence
is totally ridiculous
it doesn't work
it gives you an impossible task
what fun is it to do an impossible task
over and over again i find it agony
i just
who would want to do it hello guys
thanks for watching the video now first
i will share with you my notes and then
some personal reflections
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys that was all for today thanks
again for watching the video and if you
found the content valuable
please subscribe and give us a thumbs up
to hopefully reach other people like
minded
[Music]
you